so my original plan for today was to
talk about
my own research uh but to be honest i i
didn't really feel like it
so if you want to know more about my
research there's a great video
uh that you can watch on my web page um
that was that it
is a talk i gave it at jane street um
last uh last january i believe um
it was i'm really lucky that they
produced a good video of the talk
so um if you're interested in my
research you can go watch that i also
have other
videos and lots of blog posts and papers
and so forth
but today i was thinking i would talk
about something else so
all quarter i've been referring you to
papers and
additional reading material and some of
the topics that we've just been
discussing
and some of them i've mentioned by name
and some of them i haven't
uh but i thought that i would go through
and pick out a handful
of papers that i think are interesting
and i had a kind of fun
experience this weekend uh going through
and looking for uh primary sources on
some of the topics that we've discussed
and i actually had some interesting
discoveries which i'll try to share with
you
um so the the first thing that i want to
talk about actually
is um so i want to come back to this uh
this great illustration that that uh
chris colagan
uh shared in his talk
a few days ago so he drew a picture that
looked something like this so at the top
there was there was something called
two-phase commit
which we haven't really discussed but
we'll talk more about that in a second
um
and then paxos
or just or raft or any other consensus
protocol
a typical consensus protocol goes here
after this was something called pbft
which we didn't talk about in any detail
either so i'll talk a little bit more
about that
um and at the bottom of this he put um
blockchain consensus
and i'm going to put consensus in quotes
here
because as chris discussed it it isn't
really consensus um
so the idea is that as you get lower on
this diagram on this arrow here um
you get slower
and more fault tolerant
um i should also add slower and more
expensive to implement
so out of all this these things in this
picture the only one that we had really
talked about was paxos
so i thought we would fill in a few of
the gaps here um
so so phase commit or two pc as it's
sometimes known
um so so chris put this here um
i might have put uh primary backup
or chain replication in this spot so so
let me talk about why
um so two-phase commit uh
is a protocol where if you have a bunch
of replicas
you have a coordinator uh and the the
idea is that
everybody needs to come to a decision
about whether to abort or commit some
transaction so this is typically used in
a database setting where you have
transactions
the coordinator goes out and asks
everyone if they want to
abort the transaction or commit the
transaction so
why would a replica want to abort a
transaction when other replicas want to
commit it well it could be
something like that replica and only
that replica
doesn't have enough disk space to to
commit the transaction something like
that
so the coordinator goes out and asks
everyone if they
want to abort or commit uh and they
actually
all have to say commit so this isn't a
situation where the majority wins they
actually all have to say commit
when they all get back to the
coordinator it'll tell everybody what
the decision is so if they all said
commit
the coordinator will tell everybody okay
commit uh
and if not all of them said commit the
coordinator will say abort
um so the point is
a coordinator is needed so this is
similar
actually to um to primary backup
or chain replication
in the sense that if you want to do it
you need somebody and if you want to do
it and you want it to be fault tolerant
uh you need to have some sort of
coordination so you could do these
things
with only one coordinator uh but you
wouldn't get any fault tolerance
right and as we've discussed uh if you
want to have fault tolerance
then ultimately you're going to be
dependent on having
some sort of consensus protocol right so
we talked about how
there are different ways to replicate a
bunch of state machines right
if you use something like primary backup
or chain replication
then the coordinator process it in in
order to
to not be uh to not fail completely if
the coordinator dies
you really need a cluster of processes
that are all working as one and those
processes
uh need to be running a consensus
protocol among themselves
alternatively you could use
something like paxos or raft to do
state machine replication over all of
the processes over all of the replicas
and have them coordinate uh directly
with one another
instead of having a coordinator process
either way
you're dependent on a consensus protocol
if you want to be
tolerant of failure so in this picture
this was actually a good i think in some
ways this is a good choice to have at
the top because
two-phase commit is typically not uh
fault-tolerant in the sense that there
typically is only one coordinator
um so you might ask
um well given that
two-phase commit is something that you
might want to do
why don't we have a coordinator like or
why don't why don't we have
a cluster of processes that behave as
the coordinator instead of just having
one why don't we get rid of that single
point of failure
so and why don't we use a consensus
protocol for that
um so that in fact um has been done so
that's that's the first
paper that i want to mention to you um
it's a
classic paper so i have a whole bunch of
browser tabs here that i want to share
with you
um so the first one here is this uh a
classic paper called consensus on
transaction commit um
from jim gray and leslie lamport i think
this was from
want to say is there a date
2006 okay yeah so
note what they say here so they say i'll
make this a little bit bigger so people
can read
the classic two-phase commit protocol
blocks if the coordinator fails so
that's what we were just talking about
the coordinator is that single point of
failure
the paxos commit algorithm which is what
this paper is about
runs a paxos consensus algorithm on the
commit abort decision of each
participant
and then they say so f in this case is
the number
of um uh the number of coordinators
uh uh that can fail
so they say uh there are two there are
two
f plus one coordinators and f of them
can fail
um and they say the classic two-phase
commit algorithm in other words the
thing
that uh that chris was talking about
when you put two pc on that picture
the classic two-phase commit protocol is
the special case of pax's commit they
claim
where f equals zero in other words where
no coordinators can fail cause there's
only one
so i think this is interesting right um
they're
they're taking paxos the consensus
protocol
and plugging it into this transaction
commit
problem and saying okay well if you want
to make
transaction commit fault tolerant just
run paxos and so that's very
analogous to what we talked about in the
idea of
having a cluster of coordinators running
a consensus protocol
and those and that and those that
cluster of coordinators
behaves as a single coordinator for
something like primary backup or chain
replication
so one thing that you'll find as you
look at the literature
on consensus is that and and this was
this kind of
became clear i think in in in chris's
talk a little bit so when he was talking
about
all of these uh all of these
alternatives
um let me go back to this here
um two-phase commit paxos pbft
blockchain consensus
he was talking about them as ways to do
replication
so you might think oh well paxos isn't a
way to do replication it's a consensus
protocol but the thing is those those
two things are
really inextricably linked and one of
the most common reasons to use a
consensus protocol
is to do replication so
um so these things really are all they
really all
all do belong in that category of
techniques for doing replication
uh in the sense that replication
requires the processes
to agree and to come up with an
agreement on the order so whether you do
that
by having a coordinator who tells
everybody what the order is or whether
you do it
by having those processes all run paxos
both of those require agreement and if
you want it to also be fault tolerant if
you're doing it in the way of having a
coordinator
then that coordinator ultimately ends up
having to actually be a cluster
so okay so that's that's what two-phase
commit is um
a coordinator goes out and asks
everybody if they want to abort or
commit
they all have to say commit so it's not
a matter of majority vote
um and then the coordinator tells
everybody what the decision is
um okay so that's two-phase commit we've
talked about paxos
uh what about pvft um so this is this
stands for practical byzantine fault
tolerance
so this is a another classic paper
from 1999. um this is the work of
miguel castro and barboliskov
liskov is a legend in distributed
systems also in in the field of
programming languages uh
she developed a lot of the fundamental
theory behind object-oriented
programming
um and uh uh and
and these days her work concentrates on
distributed systems and especially
byzantine fault tolerance
um so i'm going to be honest with you
um i do not know pbft well enough to
teach it
maybe in the future i'll uh i'll find a
way to incorporate it in this class
um this is not the year but um
but i wanted to talk uh talk to you
about it for a second
um so despite practical in the name
um pbft isn't typically used in practice
that often um so i uh
it's a replication technique that
tolerates byzantine faults
um and just um
and you know you can look at this paper
if you're interested um but
just to talk a little bit about about
the characteristics of it
so in pbft
uh the property that it has
the property that it has is that n minus
over 3
out of n replicas can fail
fail simultaneously
um so fail in this case what does fail
mean well
fail doesn't just mean crash uh fail in
this case means have byzantine behavior
so a process with byzantine behavior
could be uh
pretending to fail it could have
actually failed or it could be
pretending to fail
um or it could actually be um malicious
right it could be it it could be sending
wrong information to other processes
um so so what so what does this mean
it's actually
floor of n minus one over three is the
number of of um of replicas that can
fail so let's think about what this
would mean in a real system
okay so if you let's say you had three
replicas well if you had three replicas
um so if n is three
then let's see three minus one is is two
two divided by three four of that is
zero okay so no replicas can fail if you
have three okay so that's out
um similarly if you had four
um what would happen okay four minus one
is three
three divided by three is zero yeah okay
so you can't have four
um it turns out that five is the minimum
number of replicas that you can have
in pbft uh if if if you want it to be
possible for one to fail
so this would seem to make sense right
at um just
intuitively right so we saw that with
paxos for example
um paxos um paxos can work just fine
if you have three acceptors
and one of them fails it'll still work
um because two out of three is still a
majority
so so if one of them has failed and in
that case we're just talking about uh
uh crash failures and omission failures
uh not byzantine behavior
but uh but one out of the three can fail
uh if for pbft if you want to have any
fault tolerance you need to have more
replicas
and this would seem to make sense
because uh it's a stronger notion of
fault tolerance that we're discussing
that we're discussing here so this isn't
typically done in practice because
in order to get the fault tolerance you
need more replicas which means
uh more money and replication is slower
and it's it's a bigger investment
for a kind of fault that doesn't
necessarily happen very often
depending on the particulars of the
system uh
it's great when you need it and this
paper was influential because
previous uh byzantine fault tolerant
replication strategies were slower
than pbft uh and so pbft has the
advantage that
it's uh it's it's faster than it's
faster than other known techniques
for byzantine fault tolerant replication
uh but it's still not as fast as
not using pbft so um
but i i but i felt like i ought to
mention it
uh because it is a step
uh in this picture here um
on the way to to blockchain quote
unquote consensus
so hopefully that fills in some of the
gaps for you in this picture and i think
if you took one thing away from chris's
talk it's that
everything in distributed systems is a
trade-off right as you get lower in this
picture
um you get more expensive to implement
not to mention
when you get to blockchain consensus you
get more expensive
in terms of uh in terms of actually
running it right
more expensive in terms of the
environmental impact on the world
and slower for sure um but also more
fault tolerant
um and i don't know i mean
putting consensus in quotes here is i
mean i i say that because as we talked
about
uh in chris's talk with paxos um or with
it and and and even with with pbft
there's a point at which you know
consensus has been reached and there's
no going back from it
with blockchain consensus that's not the
case
uh it's all you have is a sort of
probabilistic guarantee uh as time goes
by
so it's it's not it's not the same kind
of guarantee that consensus has been
reached that you get with these other
consensus protocols so
as chris said um you should be very
careful about
deciding to use this for consensus and
most of the time
you probably won't need it most of the
time you don't even need pbft
and honestly a lot of the time you don't
need paxos so
um that's something that we've tried to
emphasize in this course
try to try to use the the
the weakest thing that you can right um
if you can get away
without having a strong consistency
among replicas
then maybe that's a good choice or maybe
you can do some hacks to make it so that
the
so that replicas agree even if the order
of messages
isn't the same and so that's something
that we began to talk about uh
uh with um with the discussion of um
of conflict-free replicated data types
last time
okay so hopefully i've filled in a
couple of the gaps there um
i started thinking about i went back to
the beginning of the course and started
to think about all the things we've
talked about
and um uh so so one one kind of question
that that that came to mind going back
way to the beginning when we started to
talk about logical clocks
um so i wanted to know who
you know i i told you guys that
vector clocks uh were invented
by um by a couple of authors
independently so
so
and i decided to go back and fact check
myself on that um
so to remind ourselves um about vector
clocks
um first uh first let's remind ourselves
about lan port clocks
um so the next the next paper that i
have here
is the undisputed classic uh
time clocks and the ordering of events
in a distributed system this was from
leslie lamport in 1978 and
what i hear people say about this paper
is that this paper was one of the first
papers that really treated distributed
systems
as a science uh in it as opposed to
just a sort of collection of of
of tricks or heuristics um so this is
the paper that that introduced the
concept of happened before which we've
spent so much time talking about in this
class
um uh so we can
we can actually dig in and by the way so
if you look at these these pictures here
so so
these are uh among the first lanport
diagrams
uh which we've been discussing all
quarter notice that when lanport draws
them the arrows actually go up
which is kind of funny so time goes up
in these pictures
which to me makes them harder to read i
like to do time going downward
um and authors do these all kinds of
different ways sometimes you'll see
time goes left time goes right it varies
lamport is actually the only person i've
ever seen who makes time go
up in his in his lifeboard diagrams um
notice also that he makes the choice of
drawing these wavy lines to kind of
emphasize the uncertainty of the system
which is kind of funny
um but anyway so right here um
is the definition of the happens before
relation
which we've discussed um and you can go
read this paper if you want to
it's not very long let me give you just
a brief tour of the paper
so um so the beginning part of the paper
it introduces this notion of happens
before
and then he starts to talk about lanport
clocks
so this section
logical clocks um defines lampport
clocks
um where recall that a lenward clock is
just a number
rather than a vector of numbers so it's
a way of assigning a number to an event
as he says um and um
and here's the the property that we
talked about uh which he calls the clock
condition so for any two events
a and b if a happened before b the land
port clock of a is less than the land
port clock of b
and then he points out note that we
cannot expect the converse to hold so
that's what we talked about
as opposed to vector clocks of course
where we said that it's true both ways
right um but he doesn't actually invent
vector clocks in this paper that
happened later
now he goes on in this paper to use this
notion
of um so so as you know
um uh before i get to that um
so land port clocks give you a partial
order
on events um and then he says well okay
what if you wanted to turn that into a
total order
um so he says okay
well you can just use the partial order
and then
if let's say two events have the same uh
blind port clock like two events both
have the lan port clock of four
then you just use some arbitrary
ordering to break the tie
um between processes like for example um
if the processes have numbers like you
have process one and process two and
they both have an event with the lan
port clock of four
you just arbitrarily say that events on
process one happened before events on
process two so
um so that's what this says here we use
any arbitrary total
total ordering of the processes
so um that's there's there's nothing
deep going on there we're just saying
just pick any total order that that is
uh that is consistent with the partial
order
so then he goes on to say okay um
[Music]
we're gonna try to define uh
um well there's somewhere somewhere in
here let's see where does it start
um
you can see i i'm real practiced here
with this lecture
um yeah so there's there's a discussion
of
of of this idea of of implementing
uh a a distributed
mutual exclusion algorithm let's see i
can't
i can't find where that part of the
paper starts let me find it
yeah okay oh right here um
we will illustrate this the use of this
total ordering events which we just came
up with arbitrarily
um by solving the mutual exclusion
problem
um so this is the problem where you have
some resource that a bunch of processes
are supposed to share and only one of
them is supposed to have access to the
resource at a time
and so you need to find some way to
um to ensure that exactly one has access
to the resource at a time
now
nobody actually uses lamport's mutual
exclusion algorithm that's that's laid
out in this paper
um because it's not fault tolerant so
although it's a nice exercise and a
demonstration of the
of the use of of lampwork clocks
um it turns out not to be actually
particularly practically useful
um uh but it's it's interesting to look
at
um and uh and this
as i said this paper was very early in
in the development of distributed
systems so there weren't
there wasn't there weren't a whole lot
of people thinking about this right now
um uh and then he goes on
and um uh
and introduces and starts a topic talk
about this this concept
of of of state machines and notice he
mentions each process independently
simulates the execution of a state
machine um
and so this is this is kind of um a
hinting at
what people would see later with state
machine replication and so on
and then at the end of the paper he
starts to try to go back to this notion
of physical clocks
and i really don't know i'll tell you
the truth i don't know what he's talking
about
in this part of the paper it doesn't
make sense to me i think you would have
to be a physicist to understand
it um and i don't even know physicists
understand it um feel free to read it
yourself
but um but i wanted to share this paper
with you
because it's a classic and
it's uh it's probably lamport's most
cited paper
um and um so
this doesn't answer our question of who
invented vector clocks but it gives kind
of a lower bound right so this
this was the notion of of lampwork
clocks which predate vector clocks
so 1978 was when this paper came out um
and and vector clocks were soon to
follow
um so in some sense
you know maybe it doesn't really matter
um
who invented vector clocks right because
[Music]
the the idea kind of we know that the
idea arose independently in a number of
different settings
um so here's the paper that i did
recommend reading about vector clocks
um so this was not one of the one of the
primary sources on vector clocks uh this
is a paper that came later
um in the 90s so this this is the
this is the holy grail paper that i
recommended in class
i do recommend reading this uh if you
want to know a whole lot
about this this idea of
um detecting causal relationships and
distributed systems
in distributed computations um so it
starts to talk about like what would
happen if you used lan port clocks and
then here's an example of how just using
lamport clocks is insufficient
um so let's use vector clocks instead uh
is our vector clocks actually the best
solution and then some discussion of
that uh
and um so they have an interesting
footnote in here
um where um
where they say the concept of vector
time meaning vector clocks cannot be
attributed to a single person
several authors reinvented time vectors
for their purposes with different
motivation and often without knowing
uh of each other and then he mentions a
few a few citations
from the distributed database world but
then two papers
are mentioned in particular as being a
generalization of lampwork clocks
17 and 44. so these are the ones that i
mentioned to you
which were mattered in phage
so let's let's let's talk about these
so the fidge paper um
was from 1988 um
and here it is so i had to dig this one
up it was actually a little bit hard to
find
online um or it was hard to find an
authoritative version i ended up finding
this version from a
from a course taught at yale i wasn't
sure where to find a version that was
like an
author hosted version or something that
was that was hosted on
some official repository of papers i
always try to share official versions of
things when i can
um because sometimes the other versions
uh uh don't necessarily
um uh you don't know that they're gonna
remain online and so on um but this is
the best i could find for this one so
um so in this paper um
he ends up inventing vector clocks um he
doesn't call them vector clocks
um but he makes this interesting point
here um
which is that so um so with lampwork
clocks you can take them and you can
you can use the lan port clocks and then
extend that that partial order to a
total order
but then he points out this only yields
one of the many possible and equally
valid event orderings defined
and it's it's more useful to have access
to the entire partial ordering
um and
notice that there's uh so he says this
paper presents an implementation of
of the partially ordered relation
happened before happened before that is
true
for two given events if and only if
importantly this is an if and only if
here not just an if
if the first could causally affect the
second so that's that's the both ways
of the um of of what lampwork called the
clock condition
so let's let's just write that down
again um
uh so a happened before b
if and only if um the vector clock of a
is less than the vector clock of b and
that is what phage is talking about
there with that if and only if
so who invented vector clocks well it
could have been this guy
fidge colin fidge in 1988
um okay well what about the others
that we talked about so um and if you go
on and read this paper it's it's
interesting um i'm not going to go any
further into it than this
um here's the other one that was cited
in that holy grail paper as
as one of the people who extended um
uh the idea of land port clocks
actually i guess there's there was one
other thing that i wanted to talk about
in the fidget paper so if you go to
page three
yeah okay so just to just to prove to
you that this is where it's actually
discussed okay so rather than a single
integer value
time stamps are represented as an array
with an integer clock value for every
process in the network so there it is
looks like vector clocks to me
okay so here's um
here's somebody else who might have been
the inventor of vector clocks or who
simultaneously invited vector clock so
this paper
um virtual time and global states of
distributed systems
by friedman matern um so
if we look
let's see
there's some part where he starts to
talk about yeah okay
here we go in this paper we aim at
improving lamport's virtual time concept
um and so uh
he points out that vectors is a natural
representation of time in a distributed
system
and then what i think is interesting is
that
starting in section 3 he begins to talk
about the concept of consistent cuts
uh which we talked about in the context
of uh the chandy lanport algorithm
which actually predates this but what's
interesting is that
in the chandi lamport uh algorithm
so at the time that that was uh invented
um uh we didn't have vector clocks yet
so there there wasn't
uh so he's actually so in this paper
matern is actually tying together um
this notion of consistent cuts
um and notice like it's it's exactly the
idea that we talked about in class so we
said
a cut will partition a set of events
into past and future events
so a cut is a line that goes across
the process lines here um dividing into
it into past and future
and then we have this property
that we discussed in class
um
where a cut is a consistent cut
if an event's in the cut
then everything that happened before
that event happened to so that's what
this says and then there's an example of
an inconsistent cut
notice again that this is one of those
uh this is one of those sideways line
port diagrams so
in this in this one time is going to the
right
um okay
so um we'll come back to this
um this this idea of um
um of snapshots and a little bit later
but one thing i noticed as i was kind of
spelunking through these old papers to
find you know
who invented vector clocks well i i also
looked at some textbooks and
so here's one that i looked at so i
noticed that
these people said um
[Music]
the system of vector clocks was
developed independently by fidge modern
and schmuck
so i didn't know who schmuck was so i
thought okay well i'd better go look up
this schmuck person
uh so i can figure out you know who that
is and maybe that person
um it also simultaneously invented
vector clocks
so so i go to look at this up um his
name is frank schmuck
and he was a phd student at uh at
cornell
in the 80s um so the thing that's being
cited here citation 23 is actually his
phd thesis
um which is interesting right because uh
the these other people were all
established researchers uh
when they published this stuff but this
was this was in his thesis
um it didn't even appear in like a
peer-reviewed paper
so um so i had to go dig up
frank schmuck's phd thesis to learn more
and this was a little bit hard to find
online as well but i found it
so here is frank schmuck's phd thesis
from 1988
the use of efficient broadcast protocols
in asynchronous distributed systems um
he worked with ken berman at uh at
cornell
and so okay here we are it's like this
137 page document
and i wanted to dig into here to think
okay well apparently he
independently invented the notion of
vector clock somewhere in here
how am i going to find it right so so i
go in here and i'm like okay well
like you can kind of start scrolling
through um
and there's like some front matter um
right like like okay here's like the
abstract act and then
um there's gonna be like some okay
biographical sketch all right we can
learn more about
frank schmuck um there's a dedication to
his parents
um here's where he acknowledges his
advisor
and his and his uh family and and
friends
um and so on okay now we're getting into
the good stuff
um but i'm like okay this is going to
take way too long um so i'll just okay
let's just search for the word causal
right hopefully if we search for causal
we're going to start to find a
discussion of vector clocks all right so
we start to go through okay this is
promising causal broadcast
um okay so um
so we start to get to something that's
sounding good here um
based on the idea of potential causality
introduced by lanport okay so that's
sounding promising
um
[Music]
okay causal broadcast also respects fifo
ordering that's sounding like stuff that
we've talked about
um but i still don't see the part where
he actually invented vector clocks let's
keep looking
we're still only on page 28 of the whole
thesis
keep looking
causal ordering blah blah blah
okay here we go causality and time
stamps this is starting to look
promising
um okay
okay we're starting to talk about
messages that have time stamps attached
to them
what do those timestamps look like
i found this earlier but i'm just gonna
um
jump ahead okay here we go here it is
um so
here's where he defines his notion of
time stamps
a timestamp is a vector of integers
um where the entry uh
for a given process at the index in that
timestamp for a given process
is the number of events on that process
um
so and then he goes on and talks about
how you can compare time stamps and so
on
um and so there's a discussion up here
so lamport introduced logical timestamps
we can generalize this idea to
timestamps with reflect which are
vectors of integers
and here tantalizingly there's a
citation
uh sch85 this is a
so sch are the first three letters of
his name so this is a self-citation
so he's citing his own work um but if we
go and look at sch85
um f schmuck
software clocks in the order of events
in distributed system
unpublished manuscript november 1985.
okay so he's claiming
that in 1985 uh he invented this idea of
extending the the single number logical
timestamp to a vector of numbers
but um but he never published it so he's
saying that he did this in november
1985.
uh we kind of just have to believe him
um but note also
that there was a footnote here footnote
two
okay what does that say and then this is
fascinating to me the idea of vector
timestamps was developed independently
by laden and liskov in 1986 so he's like
okay who did
what's what's barbara liskov really um
did she invent timestamps
so um so this was really interesting to
me so i go and look up this citation
ll-86 so that turns out to be this paper
by barbara liskov and rivka latin two
women i might
point out um from from 1986.
so this is a paper called highly
available distributed services and
fault-tolerant garbage collection
and schmuck cited them uh
for having invented um
invented vector timestamps or vector
clocks in 1986. so
so this paper um uh
is about distributed garbage collection
one of the hardest problems
in distributed systems i'm convinced
that it's basically impossible
um so if you go through um
uh it turns out that the the the term
that they use
for i looked through this previously so
otherwise i wouldn't know this but the
the the term that they use for vector
clocks is multi-part time steps
um uh so
here's a discussion of time stamps
um multi-part timestamps where there is
one part for each replica
thus if there are n replicas a timestamp
uh has
parts that are integers for one through
n replicas
and then um they also point out since
there will typically be a small number
of replicas eg three to seven
using such a time stamp is practical
um so and then they go on and talk about
how you update time stamps
uh how you how you merge time stamps and
so forth
so this is yet another place where this
idea of
um of of
of time stamps arose um so going back to
to our our list here so
so we had fidge and matern who who both
published their papers in 1988
there was um schmuck
whose thesis came out in 1988
um but he cited himself uh
having done this in 1985 and then
there's
liz kovan laden from 1986. so i find
this interesting right because
i always hear these three names or i
always hear these two names mentioned
and then sometimes this name that gets
mentioned but i never hear these names
getting mentioned um to answer this
question of who invented vector clocks
so i might do a little bit more digging
on this but i might i might end up
having to write a blog post
um about this okay so
so cool so i learned something new this
weekend about the history of distributed
systems
all right so we're up to the late 80s by
this point um
uh i mentioned that that schmuck was a
student at cornell
and he was um he was working uh with
this guy ken berman
so there's a really wonderful vermin
paper it's like so i kind of skipped
over some stuff in
in schmuck's dissertation about um uh
causal broadcast and so forth um so
um so my my favorite
um paper on that topic is is this one uh
by by ken berman and his collaborators
um
uh called lightweight causal and atomic
group broadcast or
excuse me atomic group multicast um
so it's about this system that they
built at cornell called isis
um the name of it didn't really age well
um but
it uh it's there's some interesting
distributed systems ideas in this paper
and so uh there's um
there's a there's a discussion of causal
broadcast uh which we also discussed in
class
um so i want to talk about that a little
bit um
so let's see so
when we talked about causal broadcast
let me let me actually bring up
um the relevant parts of this paper so
first there's a discussion of of vector
clocks i'm going to skip ahead the early
stuff in the paper which talks about
isis
and the isis system um and then there's
a whole bunch of like kind of
introductory stuff
and the system model and so forth i'm
going to skip past all of that
and go to the part of the paper that
starts to talk about
about vector clocks and then causal
broadcast
so let's see waiting for it to load
okay so here we go so
oops i guess we went too far
okay so section four of the paper talks
about vector clocks or effects section
4.3 actually
um
so here's this is this is exactly what
we talked about in class when we talked
about vector clocks
um so if you have a process
at the start of execution it has a
vector clock of all zeros
every time you do a send its position in
the vector clock gets incremented
messages have vector clocks piggyback
along with them
and when a process receives a vector
clock it gets merged with its own vector
clock
um and then that ends up being the
foundation
of how they implement causal broadcast
which is discussed in the next section
so this cb
cast here um which is what most of this
paper is about
stands for causal broadcast um so here's
the causal broadcast algorithm that's in
this paper
right here starting at where it says the
protocol is as follows
so before sending a message you
increment its vector clock
um and you you add you timestamp the
message with the vector clock
here's the key part when you get a
message you don't deliver the message
yet
delay delivery of the messages until
um uh
until this is true so you have to make
sure that
um you you have to you have to make sure
of of two things
one you have to make sure that the the
received clock is one bigger than the
local clock in the center's position
that's what this first part says and
then you have to make sure that
the received clock is less than or equal
to
the local clock in every other position
and that's what we talked about in class
um so
this is what they said now then they say
okay
when a message is delivered when when
those rules are met and you get to
actually deliver a message
then then you update your local clock in
accordance with the vector time protocol
that we talked that was previously
discussed
so what we said when we talked about
about causal broadcast as we said when
you deliver a message
you just increment the local clock in
the sender's position
what they said is just use the standard
vector clock thing of merging the local
clock and the received
clock and take the point wise maximum of
the two clocks
um so that's what they say here when
they say vector clock is updated in
accordance with the vector time protocol
they they say do the usual vector clock
thing of just merging the clocks
it turns out that these are equivalent
actually so so some people
asked you know when we talked about
causal broadcast in class
some people asked why um
what why are wha why don't aren't we
going to merge these clocks don't we
have to merge the clocks
so it turns out that these are
equivalent
because of the conditions on on when
it's safe to deliver a message
so because it has to be the case
that the received clock is bigger than
the local clock
by one in the center's position and also
every other position has to be less than
or
equal to the local clock it turns out
that merging the clocks
and just doing this increment the local
clock in the center's position
it turns out that these two things
actually result in the same thing
um so like just for example
um
like if you had the clock on uh if your
process had the clock i don't know
um one four or five
and you receive a clock um so let's say
let's say that your
um let's say these entries are like for
processes a b and c respectively and
your process a
and let's say that you that you receive
a message
um uh from process b
um that's something like um
i don't know um one five
three so you get a message from process
b
with this clock um so the way that we
talked about causal broadcast was we
said
um you uh
you increment the local clock in the
sender's position so that would leave
you with
one five three
or excuse me it would leave you with one
five five
so that's what you would get if you
incremented the local clock in the
center's position
but if you just merge the clocks
according to the point wise maximum
then you also get one five five so these
two things do the same thing because of
the conditions on when it's safe to
deliver
this one happens to be safe to deliver
because it meets those criteria of
being one big than the local clock in
the center's position because it came
from process b
um and it's less than or equal to the
local clock in every other position and
the
one here is less than or equal to one
three is less than or equal to five
i don't know where i learned my version
of this algorithm the version where you
just increment the local clock in the
center's position
in retrospect it seems like a like a
um kind of an obvious optimization right
like
if you can just increment a number and
then have that be the same
as what you would get if you were to um
actually take the maximum of all these
numbers
then why would you not do that right why
would you not do the the thing that's
easier to compute
um but i don't remember where i learned
my version and it was interesting to
look back
at this um at this burman paper uh
that introduced this idea of causal
broadcast and to see that that
they actually didn't do uh that
optimization
of just increment the local clock in the
center's position at least i don't see
anywhere in here where they talk about
that
um so i don't know where i learned my
version um
i didn't i know i i didn't invent it um
i learned it somewhere but i don't
remember where
um and so if anybody knows where that
came from uh let me know
um okay so we're up to the 90s now in
our little tour through history
um i'd like to keep going uh we're i may
not get through actually all the papers
that i wanted to get through
um let's see um
let me let me let me pause at this point
and look at chat and see what what
questions people might have if any
yeah so there's some good comments here
um so
um
so so um yeah somebody's pointing out
the
the work on communicating sequential
processes yeah um from horror
yeah um so yeah so this was this was
great foundational work
on on concurrency um
i came to distributed systems from
programming languages
so i my my background is much more to do
with this
uh um uh reasoning about concurrency
from programming language's point of
view than from a distributed systems
point of view
these days um i'm excited about
distributed systems because these
the questions of fault tolerance aren't
necessarily discussed so often
uh in the pl setting i i get excited
when a pl paper does discuss those
things and i'm actually really
interested in the intersection of these
areas
but um
but yeah um the the csp work was
was incredibly important in foundational
and yes i also feel a little bad for
frank schmuck um
for having the last name schmuck it's
kind of unfortunate
all right um moving on
okay so i was you know i was going to
say a little bit more about um about
snapshots um
but i think i just want to share one
really nice thing from this paper so
this was the chandy lanport uh
algorithm this is the paper that
introduced the candy lampport algorithm
uh in 1985. um
and and there's a really just a
beautiful quotation in here that i want
to share
i don't actually recommend this paper as
a way to learn the algorithm i i think
this paper is hard to understand
um but i but i want to share this this
this quote because i think it's really
lovely
uh so they
they they call they they describe their
algorithm as a state detection algorithm
so
uh what they're trying to do if you
recall what a snapshot is it's trying to
understand
the global state of a distributed system
and trying to get uh to get a coherent
overall view of the state of a
distributed system
so they say the state detection
algorithm plays the role of a group of
photographers
observing a panoramic dynamic scene such
as a sky
filled with migrating birds a scene so
vast that it cannot be captured by a
single photograph
the photographers must take several
snapshots and piece the snapshots
together to form a picture of the
overall scene
the snapshots cannot all be taken at
precisely the same instant because of
synchronization problems
furthermore the photographers should not
disturb the the process that is being
photographed so we talked about that
right we talked about how the chandelier
algorithm can run at the same time as
the application that it's snapshotting
for instance they cannot get all the
birds in the heavens to remain
motionless while the photographs are
taken
yet the composite picture should be
meaningful the problem before us is to
define meaningful and then to determine
how the photograph should be taken
uh so i find this analogy really
beautiful and really nice and trying to
understand the challenge of trying to
snapchat distributed systems
you can't take a picture of every
process at the same time because there
is no global notion of time
and and you certainly can't uh
get all the birds to hold still so
or or if you did you know if you you
could in fact
so you certainly can't get the birds to
hold still right you could actually
pause all the processes in a distributed
system but you really would like to
avoid that if at all possible
so i think this is a really lovely
quotation that kind of describes
what they're after here
okay moving on to a different topic um
so then
so after we talked about um about vector
clocks and causal broadcasts
and consistent cuts and and snapshots we
started to talk about replication in
this course right and the first
replication
strategy that we talked about was
primary backup
if you go and look and you try to find
okay who is the first to come up with
primary backup um
this is the paper that tends to get
cited um by alzberg and day
this was from the 70s let's see if
there's a date on here
okay 1975
so this is the paper that you always
find cited um
i started to look through here and it
didn't see
it didn't seem to feel to me like it was
particularly close to what we think of
as primary backup replication today i
believe that these guys were first
um but i wouldn't necessarily recommend
this paper as a way to learn what
primary backup replication
is because it doesn't look a whole lot
like what i now think of as primary
backup replication
um nevertheless i think it's important
to mention it to point out that
that the primary backup replication is
an old idea notice that they're
um that they're motivating this idea of
replication
um by um by so first of all notice okay
the development of large packet switched
networks
as opposed to circuit switched networks
you know packet switch networks where
packets can be lost
and um and where um
uh and and where um
availability is an issue right um
uh it's a it's a challenging environment
to work in
and so they're motivating it by talking
about these these pre-internet
networks um like arpanet um so these
were
the old days right and so um
it's very interesting sometimes to read
these old papers um
and and just think about think about the
perspective that they had and then think
about how well did this hold up
with the way that we think about these
these things today
um and often you know like some of the
assumptions that they made are
surprisingly uh surprisingly still make
sense today and
and you can really admire the authors
for having uh
having such a such an amazing vision
other times
uh the the assumptions that they made uh
don't make sense at all today um
so this is who you see cited for
inventing primary backup
um i wanted to point out some work
that's a lot more recent
and uh and closer to home so so here's a
paper from
our own ucsc um this has to do with the
um the ceph
system ceph is a distributed
um some people call it a file system uh
some people call it an object store
um uh so it's a it's a distributed
storage system
uh and i wanted to bring this up because
um
uh there's a there's a nice illustration
in here of
um of what they came up with um
which is kind of a um a
hybrid of of primary backup and chain
replication so there's this really nice
figure here
um in this paper um from 2007
about um the replication strategy that
they came up with that kind of merges
uh primary backup and chain replication
so the first part here
so primary copy this is a synonym for
primary backup if you see people talking
about primary backup
or if you see people talking about
primary copy that means the same thing
as primary backup
so this should look familiar to you uh
we've talked about primary backup
already
both reads and writes go to the go to
the um
the primary the primary is this one
right here
um osd uh is a is a notion that's
specific to
ceph which is what this paper is about
but just think of it as a replica
um and then this over here is the client
um
so both reads and rights go here notice
that there's a delay
uh because the the primary has to go out
and talk to all the backups wait for
them to acknowledge it and then get back
to the client
um chain replication which we've already
talked about
um the primary passes rights on to the
backups and then
the the tail of the chain acknowledges
the client
um what they came up with which is kind
of in some ways a combination of the two
is what they call splay replication so
in splay replication
um the rights go to the the head
of the chain but then the head of the
chain in parallel sends the
update all out to everybody else
um and then each of those has to
acknowledge the tail
so the delay is incurred there's there's
there's still a bit of delay right
so delay is incurred at the tail here
between the time when the tail gets this
right and the time that it gets these
messages
and it and that right there is the
commit point so
this what they call apply right in this
picture is what we called commit point
um well i guess i guess they're they're
talking about applying the right on all
of them
uh so i guess we should think of so this
one here is the commit point for
um uh for primary backup
this one is the commit point for chain
replication
and this one is the commit point for
splay replication
um so there's a little bit of a of a
time savings here because these messages
from the primary get sent out in
parallel uh to all of these
uh replicas and then the tail
acknowledges the client just like
with chain replication um so
according to them this helps minimize uh
right latency
um so um so so i think this is kind of
interesting that even in
in 2007 people were still um uh
coming up with uh with new ways to
improve
uh um strongly consistent replication
strategies and they're still coming up
with ways to do it today
okay so there's that um
all right so that's it for replication
um
on to i guess if we have any time left
yeah we have about three minutes left
yeah okay just enough time to start to
talk about um
um uh consensus a little bit
so i would relax if i didn't mention the
raft paper
um so so here's the paper on the raft
consensus algorithm which came out in
this is the long version uh which is i
think longer than the version that
appeared
at atc um so
i think what's interesting as you look
at this paper is so
i mean there's a couple things about it
that are interesting you know they
emphasize understandability of the
algorithm versus paxos
and they um they actually go to the
trouble of having a user study in this
paper
uh where they ask people questions about
both paxos and raft
and and ask them you know which is
easier to understand
um right up front they acknowledge their
debt to
previous work and one of the
the particular things that they that
they emphasize uh
that their work is similar to is the
work on view stamped replication which
we briefly mentioned
so i so i thought i would mention this
paper as well um
um note here that right in the title um
they they call this a primary copy
method or a primary backup method
um so what's interesting here right is
it's like well i told you v stamped
replication was it was a consensus
protocol
but they're saying that this is a
replication strategy
uh right here and so well aren't those
different things and so again i would go
back to what i said at the beginning of
of class and i'd say they're not that
different right because
it so what what they do in this paper is
present a replication strategy and then
point
out that you need to have consensus in
order to make this replication strategy
work
and the core idea of vue stamp
replication
is that consensus protocol that they
came up with
um so um so once again it's it's it's
barbara liskov who
um uh who is um
uh the the primary investigator on this
work
um brian okey uh was her student and i
think he's at
microsoft research now uh continuing to
do awesome work
um i could be wrong it might i can't
remember if it's him that's at osr or
somebody else
um uh but um
one thing that's interesting about both
this and raft is that they don't say
they don't set out to say so much like
we're going to do a consensus algorithm
they set out to say we want to do
replication
in order to do replication we need
consensus
and so we're going to tailor our
consensus protocol and everything about
it to the particular use case of needing
to do replication
and so unlike paxos right where
uh with paxos you have to extend it to
multipaxos and you have to do certain
optimizations and so on in order
to make it suitable for the setting of
replication
uh with these things they just assume
that replication is the thing that you
want to do right from the start
um and these these different consensus
protocols um uh
they they turn out to have a lot in
common i think i mentioned this paper
briefly in class this paper that
contrasts paxos and viewstamp
replication and zab
the zookeeper atomic broadcast protocol
which we briefly talked about
um so this paper points out their their
similarities and differences
um but they they really do all have a
lot in common
um and what i found the the feature of
this paper that i liked the most
is that there's a there's a um a table
in here that's almost like a rosetta
stone
of of terminology right here so at the
top of this page
uh translation between terms used in
this paper and the various replication
protocols under consideration
so they're contrasting paxos vsr and zab
and they're
um they're for every one of these terms
like you see paxos there's like learner
acceptor leader
they talk about how in each of these
other systems
there's the same concept but under a
different name and so
when i first looked at this paper and i
flipped the page to this table i
actually gasped because
it is it's so interesting to me that all
of these people
ended up with very similar ideas but
going by different names very common in
computer science but
but this this table really lays it out
very starkly
and of course not all of the ideas um
are in all of these systems uh but
i i i think it's really fascinating and
then if you can read this paper you can
read this paper in much more depth to
get a clearer idea of the differences
um and very recently um heidi howard and
richard mortier
uh wrote a paper about um comparing
pexos and raft and just kind of saying
like are they really so different after
all
and they what they end up doing is
uh describing a simplified version of
paxos using the terminology of raft
so in this paper the this this van
renison schneider paper
they talked about paxos vsr and zeb they
didn't even talk about raft at all it
was
it was actually kind of throwing shade
on raft they didn't talk about it
because raft had just recently come out
and was very popular
but this paper actually compares paxos
and raph directly
uses uh raf terminology to talk about
paxos it ends up showing that
paxos and raft aren't that different and
the
the popularity of raft can largely be
attributed to the fact that
it uh is is easier to understand
and uh and there's this nice uh paper
that
it it makes it quite straightforward to
implement raft from the paper
as opposed to paxos which is very hard
to implement from a paper
so that's it um that's our tour through
the last
uh several decades of some
we only scratched the surface but
there's some several decades of papers
and distributed systems that i
that i thought i would mention to you we
looked at like 16 or so
um i can share the links later if you're
interested
um but that's it for today uh we will
see you next time
for our guest speaker chris and mckelvey
and
take care of yourselves bye